l'accès aux positions des artilleurs de
la 35ème brigade de marine donne une
idée de la physionomie du champ de
bataille des hectares de bocage où il
faut à la fois tenir et progresser
l'endroit où on peut se reposer un peu
on est là pour quelques jours sur cette
position voilà c'est l'endroit le plus
sûr qu'on est pour se mettre à l'abri
et au perd un canon de 122 mm qui date
de l'air soviétique et malgré la
contre-offensive les munitions ne sont
pas illimitées
tout dépend des livraisons de nos
partenaires étrangers en vérité pour les
phases actives on a vraiment besoin de
plus de munitions vraiment beaucoup plus
en face les forces russes ne semblent
pas faire à l'économie
après plus d'un an sur le front rares
sont les soldats qui prête attention aux
obus qui s'abattent à proximité
il nous attaque régulièrement ici mais
quand on était sur la direction de
marinska par exemple il nous jetait
beaucoup plus d'obus il nous faisait
partir de nos positions et on était
forcés de bouger trois ou quatre fois
par jour
sont déployés sur l'axe de progression
vers la mer d'Azov et la grande ville de
Mario Paul une motivation supplémentaire
pour Vitali originaire de la cité
portuaire prise par les forces russes
l'année dernière
peu importe l'état dans lequel est la
ville ma maison est toujours debout
grâce à Dieu même après tout ça après
tous les bombardements
mais je prie pour que les autres se
retirent sans combattre parce que s'il y
a une seconde bataille ce sera comme un
barmut
un avion de chasse l'arc de ces bombes
l'inquiétude fugace tous restent
concentrés alors tâche